the Environmental Protection Agency the
EPA under the current administration has
been pretty reminiscent of George
Orwell's Newspeak it's the opposite of
its name right it's still called the
Environmental Protection Agency but its
director
Scott Pruett has worked for years before
he was EPA director to stop the EPA from
protecting the environment by filing
many many lawsuits and EPA policy under
Scott Pruett has moved in the complete
opposite direction of actual
transparency and this is now sort of
culminating with the EPA banning The
Associated Press and CNN as well as
another environmentally focused news
agency called a and E from attending a
national summit that they're running on
contaminants in our drinking water now
contaminants in our drinking water
massive issue right we've got of course
the Flint Michigan situation which is
still not fully resolved by the way I
mean it's been years at this point that
this has been going on we're polluting
our oceans in a devastatingly disastrous
way contaminants in our drinking water a
big big deal and EPA director Scott
Pruitt truly one of the most dark and
depraved players in the Trump
administration put this event together
and in explaining why CNN and The
Associated Press aren't being allowed in
the EPA spokesman Jehan Wilcox says they
weren't invited and that there was
simply no room for them which is kind of
weird right because as we found out when
a reporter from The Associated Press
showed up at this event
guards physically prevented him from
going through security screening when he
said if I can't get in I want to speak
to someone from the EPA's public affairs
department and security subsequently
grabbed the guy by the shoulders and
shoved him out of the building and to
say that this is nothing more than
oh there simply wasn't room that's
obviously the safest thing for them to
say but it's still actually incredibly
problematic because there's a court case
called Cheryl Cheryl V night back from
1977 where a US Court of Appeals ruled
that an administrator
can't deny passes to the press
specifically saying that individual news
men cannot be arbitrarily excluded from
the sources of information so the
question is was this arbitrary if this
is because the EPA and the Trump
administration don't like CNN which we
know that they don't or they don't like
The Associated Press that would be an
example of arbitrary if this is because
there is literally not room for a single
additional person in the room I guess
it's not arbitrary in that sense but how
do you really prove that there wasn't
room right it seems very hard to imagine
yeah I mean if I was coming up with a
list of outlets to invite because there
was a limited amount of space yeah I
feel like The Associated Press will be
number one on that list like they have
to be there because there perhaps the
most respected news agency out there may
be number two would be Reuters or number
three would be I don't know but CNN
could be a little bit down the list I
just wonder if like Fox News and the
Drudge Report and Breitbart got access
because that would be totally egregious
you would think that the AP would be
high on the list of who you would want
there the problem though is that The
Associated Press recently broke a story
about Donald Trump's dealing with crown
princes and other fortune seekers from
around the world exposing the corruption
of the Trump administration and there's
speculation that even though yes on the
fact the AP is actually considered one
of the least biased and most accurate
sort of reporting agencies in the United
States that the Trump administration and
by extension the EPA are not pleased
with the AP because of that and we know
that the Trump administration is at war
with CNN right that one's not surprising
whatsoever so will we ever know the
truth probably not like with most things
in this administration but this is part
of a trend that we're seeing and we're
also seeing the trend we talked to
earlier in the week about regulatory
capture right when you see agencies
controlled by the people they're
supposed to be regulating in this case
we are also seeing the EPA more and more
under the control of the polluters that
they're supposed to be regulating and
these are efforts to silence press
keeping press out of events the
suggestion of expanding libel lawsuits
the government's idea of
maybe ranking what are trustworthy and
untrustworthy news outlets incredibly
dangerous idea as we spoke about
yesterday with David Patrick Caracas
taking away journalism licenses we don't
even really know what those are but
Donald Trump talked about taking away
journalism licenses or requiring
journalism licenses no matter whether
they're clueless when they say it or not
this is a horribly authoritarian
tendency and this is one of the major
meta issues right press freedom along
with campaign finance net neutrality
which relates to press freedom
as well as climate change these are sort
of the meta issues and we are seeing
just decidedly and totally definitive a
definitive rather definitive oh boy
that's a hope that doesn't pop up on
Urban Dictionary anytime soon a
definitive move towards authoritarianism
I want to hear from you about this what
do you think is behind this decision
what do you think about this move that
we're seeing very authoritarian move on
media I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on Twitter at David Pakman show
it's just the best program today the
Friday show we'll be taking calls
answering your questions and so much
more
today's episode of the David Pakman show
is made possible in part by the master
crypto currency trader an online course
created by crypto 80 this is a fantastic
new class for anyone who's new to the
world of crypto currency and Bitcoin and
maybe you've heard about crypto
currencies you don't know much about it
you don't have any idea how to get
started this is the perfect way to do it
and the course was designed by veteran
crypto investor Chris Kony who has more
than 10 years experience in currency
trading and he starts out teaching you
all the sort of core concepts in a way
that's really easy to absorb he lays out
a simple step-by-step system for making
smart decisions as a trader and by the
time you're done with the course you'll
have all the tools and knowledge you'll
need to get started in the world of
trading crypto currencies of course the
usual legal disclaimer I have to tell
you I'm not giving you financial advice
but I am telling you that the course is
definitely worth checking out you can
get 25% off by going to
tripped over city.com / Pakman and when
you sign up using that link you'll get
250 bucks worth of Bitcoin but only if
you go to crypt / city.com / Pakman and
the first 50 people who sign up will get
this special deal that c ry PT o ve RS
ity comm / PA k ma n if you're watching
this on youtube i've put a link
underneath the video